i think what you're doing here with the
community center
will equip folks and that in turn will
bring businesses into this environment
because they'll see the the quality of
the labor force that literally comes
through the doors of what you're
creating here
[Music]
can you believe it that's right i'm
still here living inside this tent on
top of this rooftop bringing to you the
issues and awareness that you need to
know about violence on the south side of
chicago but also to raise as much money
as possible to build a community center
on this block called o block it's called
o block because it's named after a young
man named od perry who was shot and
killed the gang simply owe in his name
and start calling it oh block we decided
to keep the o but we're going to change
it to opportunity block i want to thank
fox for giving me the opportunity every
single day to bring to you rooftop
revelations where i share with you my
thoughts viewpoints and opinions on
matters as it relates to violence on the
south side of chicago and issues that we
face in our great country and every now
and then
i get to bring you some very special
guests so today i have a guest with us
who's staying all night on the rooftop
part of our ceo challenge i'm going to
let him introduce himself right now
go ahead john
thank you pastor yeah john reeves from
san diego california i'm the ceo of
milton's craft bakers
we've got a team that's passionate about
bringing joy to people through delicious
food and also giving back to our
community and this is a great great
opportunity for us to do just that
absolutely well let me just say you know
it takes a lot of courage and a lot of
heart to leave sunny san diego
and come with us
on the south side of chicago but i'm
glad you did it i'm glad you're here
glad to be here you know my mentor says
something like this that
uh when it comes to business that
business is the magic
that cures social ills
that capitalism not dependency
is the answer
with that being said
tell us how you think
capitalism and creating businesses
can answer some of the social ills that
we face especially here on the south
side of chicago
yeah really focusing here
uh with you pastor on on the south side
of chicago
the way that business can help is is by
providing opportunity
this this neighborhood this community
really needs peace and the opportunity
for prosperity that's what project hood
is all about and that's what milton's
and my team are about
helping and supporting
uh your team
is providing skills to folks um
providing an opportunity for um you know
peace and joy in their day especially
this community center that you're
seeking to build uh it's gonna provide
training to thousands of people
and those people are then well equipped
so they can come to work for companies
around here and in other cities
and we want to be a part of that
absolutely you know when you talk about
creating a peaceful environment in our
center trying to help transform this
neighborhood
why is it so important that from your
standpoint
um
that
businesses help to anchor that you know
help us to create an ecosystem for
um for creating economic base sure yeah
sure i mean you're you're helping equip
uh you know individuals uh with skills
and a real good understanding of how to
take that next step
uh it's my job it's ceo's jobs to
provide the economic opportunity
and with that just the opportunity to
earn a great paycheck and take care of
themselves and earn their way and
support their families absolutely
so so why is it so difficult then like
one of the things i've noticed about our
neighborhood is that there's such a lack
of strong businesses you know we got mom
and pop businesses which are important i
don't want to demean them by any stretch
of the imagination but
as far as getting established like like
your company we don't have anything like
that in our neighborhood how is it that
we get companies like that to come to
areas like this or or is it even
possible it's absolutely possible
uh it starts with leadership quite
honestly i think it starts with your
leadership okay uh that's why i came
from southern california
to be with you and to partner with you
on this journey i think what you're
doing here with the community center
will equip folks and that in turn will
bring businesses into this environment
because they'll see the
the quality of the labor force that
literally comes through the doors of
what you're creating here
i think you just said something key i
think
uh it has to be a give and take that a
lot of times
when companies start feeling like and
correct me if i'm wrong but when
companies are feeling like they don't
have a good work force to choose from
there's uh
that that what's the what's the use of
going into an area if there if there's
no potential there uh so how do we get
people to realize businesses to realize
is it more than just marketing what is
it how can we get them to realize that
hey there's some untapped talent here
there's some potential here um and we're
willing to give you the skills we're
willing to give people the skills how do
we get people
ceos
to take that leap was make that
investment yeah to make that investment
uh i i think it's uh that will follow
your success
um currently you're already equipping
people with with key job skills uh in
the area of trucking uh and banking and
and other disciplines yes and and
they're finding opportunities maybe
adjacent to the neighborhood absolutely
and that model of success uh will build
on itself and ultimately attract
companies that are willing to locate
absolutely
well you know i'm really grateful for
you being here like i said it takes a
lot to come all the way from san diego
and and participate
i want to ask you why why are you here
though you know you know
san diego's nice and sunny and warm i
can still see your tan a little bit
and uh
but why come to chicago why come to the
south side why come on this room why
stay all night why participate in this
endeavor the ceo challenge
it really is grounded in one thing and
that is this neighborhood deserves peace
and it deserves prosperity
uh i saw you on tv some year ago uh and
immediately got behind you
so did my team yeah and so um we've got
to solve this problem
and
uh you know the challenges that this
community community faces are best
solved by those who live here
who know the people
uh who care the most about it so when
you see a bright shining light
stand atop a roof
for 95 days yeah
how can you not go help um
i ask everyone to join us uh in
supporting project hood
you can go online and and donate uh it
is an absolute worthy cause it's going
to transform this neighborhood
well i appreciate you uh not just for
tonight's support but like you said the
support that you and your company your
family have been giving us over time uh
it means a lot and i appreciate uh
having ceos like yourself believe in us
that we can transform our neighborhood
that
individuals uh are worth giving a second
chance and another opportunity so i
really appreciate it
cheers man all right thanks i hope you
sleep well tonight don't get too cold
i hope i did too all right so listen
it's awesome i want to thank eli steele
for producing this great show as always
shouts out to terrell for filming in the
cold weather it's getting ready to snow
a little bit and as always i'm extremely
grateful and thankful to fox for giving
me an opportunity every single day to
share with you rooftop revelations i
realize that the fox
does not have to give me this
opportunity but they do this platform
has been a tremendous blessing to all of
us here on the south side of chicago to
communicate our truths and to
communicate communicate our point of
view of what's happening on the south
side so thank you so very much and as i
always say another rooftop revelation
god bless you
god bless america and until tomorrow
another rooftop revelation peace
[Music]
[Music]
you